[Music]
hello
in the last video miss coffee bean
presented a couple of definitions of
multimodal machine learning
even came up with the definition of her
own
there we learned how images are one
modality and language is another
modality
so we will spend this in the next video
to talk about how neural networks have
problems combining vision and language
problems
what are you talking about deep learning
has had a lot of success over the last
years
take for example the case of visual
question and answering or short bqa
deep neural networks have no problems to
answer questions related to images and
even show us what they are looking at
while giving the answer
or do they
one more example on visual dialogue
where neural systems deliver the state
of the art
in chatting with the user about an image
the visual dialogue challenge website
even comes with a
visual chatbot demo we have to try it
out
we upload our favorite image
and we see that model
thinks it is a close-up of a mouse and a
mouse what is the mouse doing
i can't tell why is the mouse running
i don't know is this really a mouse
yes are you sure yes
you are wrong yes
okay let's try with another image where
i think that the model will recognize
something
yes it's a woman standing in front of a
red
building okay what is the red
building i can't tell
what can you tell i have no idea
wow no well no
where is the woman on a sidewalk i can
agree to that
right is the building beautiful no
do you know what beautiful means
no okay bye
seeing the success stories being
reported in papers
papers tell only success stories nobody
reports about failed experiments
yeah you're right is coffee bean don't
interrupt me
so i was saying after reading about all
these success stories i got a little
suspicious
and hired a world-class detective
miss copybean to conduct a private
investigation
she could go and find out what is really
going behind the multimodal scenes
of vision and language we now switch to
her
miss coffee bean where do vision and
language models fail and why
what did you find i have travelled the
fast paper wasteland
why is my voice so strange i have
traveled the vast paper wasteland
and i finally found the pot full of
proofs
telling us that we should keep a
critical
eye pointed to multimodal systems
let's see what i have in this pot first
on my journey i encountered the
symptom of the disease the symptom
seems to show systems that tend to
forget about one modality
visual or textual and focused almost
completely on the other
and this although we are trying to solve
multimodal tasks
where it is essential to combine the
information from two or more modalities
to gain an answer based on both an
answer that should be not possible to
give
when looking at only one modality
this symptom of ignoring one modality
and focus on the other can be seen in a
very interesting investigation of this
paper
the authors take a very common
multimodal architecture from 2019
where features are extracted from vision
and language respectively
by two different branches
then these features representing
different modalities are concatenated
further transformed by a linear layer
followed by non-linear activation and
ta-da
this is the multi-modal representation
containing information from both
modalities
with this representation further task
specific layers
enable the model to predict the answer
for the task
like the answer to how many cups are
there in the image
and the answer would be here too with
this architecture the authors train a
well-performing vqa model on the vqa
data set
but then they want to test it to see how
well the model considers
both modalities when delivering the
answer for this they do crazy things
with the data set
they replace nouns in half of the image
captions with
other nouns so that they do not fit the
picture anymore
then they let the same learned weights
from the vqa task
predict whether the caption does fit the
image or not
for more information on this diagnostic
procedure check out our video on probing
linked below so do we expect from a
model that performs well
on vqa delivering right answers to
questions about the image
to recognize that the caption does not
fit the image anymore
yes we do expect this only that the mod
does not notice the change for telling
whether the caption fits the image or
not it performs with the same accuracy
as random
chance disappointing
and the authors do not restrict
themselves to
vqa but test also the same neural
architecture on other tasks like
visual dialogue and phrase localization
the models trained specifically for
understanding the relations between
images and text
are not able to tell if the captions
have been altered or not
this raises serious questions like how
is then the model able to perform well
in vqa
in the first place if it clearly does
not understand the relationship between
the image and the text
another study indicating that multimodal
models
ignore one modality was conducted on
multi-modal machine translation
where the model had to translate from
source to target language
but this time with the help of images
only that the model performance on
translating image captions did
not differ convincingly when having
access to the image compared to not
looking at the image
at all only when many tokens from the
text were deleted
and the text barely contained some
information for the model to rely on
the multimodal model started to focus on
the
image of course there's a lot to discuss
here
about the task of multi-modal machine
translation itself
where we could argue if we delete the
text
it becomes more image captioning than
multi-modal machine translation or we
could even ask
if multi-modal machine translation is a
sensible task
in the first place why are we requiring
images at all
regarding the latter i will try to
convince you that images are helpful
just think about cases of disambiguation
where if i tell you get in the car it
would be very helpful for me to
translate this
to also have a picture of an automobile
or
a train car or think about misspellings
in the text
and so on so far we have seen the
symptom
of the multimodal illness in vision and
language
one modality especially the visual one
is taken too little into account even
ignored
only the textual modality seems to
contribute heavily
raising serious concerns about the
success of multi-modal integration
miss coffee bean why is this on my
journey i encountered two sources of all
evil but about this in the next video
see you then can't wait
disclaimer this video highlights the not
so favorable aspects of integrating
vision and language for information on
risk and side effects please read your
favorite publication and ask your
machine learning researcher or engineer
you